[Music]
Quebec's power struggle on this Saturday
night we've called the hydro Quebec
multiple times how many people will be
in the dark for the fourth night in a
row and why some repairs will take
longer
America's abortion access in legal limbo
this decision is clearly about ideology
and politics two conflicting court
rulings Paving the way for a potential
Showdown a Canadian couple's nightmare
in Florida
why they can't get a hospital bed back
home and harnessing the healing power of
Harmony
the cancer center using the sound of
music to soothe Souls
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us frustrations are mounting in Quebec
as tens of thousands of families are
still without power for the fourth night
after a fierce ice storm earlier this
week yesterday Premier Francois Lego
promised 95 of people would have power
back by tonight but that still hasn't
happened in fact efforts to restore
power have slowed down as some of the
outages are taking longer to repair more
than a hundred thousand Hydro Quebec
customers are still in the dark many of
them are in the greater Montreal area
and as Elizabeth zogales reports some
are understandably losing patience
the lights should be on for most
quebecers by Easter Sunday according to
hydro Quebec the the bulk part of our
distribution system has been restored so
now we are uh we are doing some work on
uh outages with a smaller amount of
customer 1500 workers are on the ground
facing the tedious task of fixing Fallen
power lines caused by tree branches some
of those outages take longer time to
repair our more difficult to move people
to uh to be able to intervene at those
specific point on our system but in the
greater Montreal area frustration is
growing as some prepare to spend their
fourth night in the dark we've called
the hydro Quebec multiple times because
a tree fell on the power line in your
house and it's dangerous
and his mother Ada live in a Montreal
suburb where many residents are dealing
with fallen down power power lines I
called with your Quebec and I sent a lot
of email last year for hydro Quebec in
city and say these trees have problems
but melting around 70 warming centers
across Quebec are set up with chargers
snacks and showers for residents some
even allow pets you can try to look at
the positive side as the weather warms
flooding is now also a growing concern
in parts of Southern Quebec 250 houses
it has been they've been pumped out
yesterday so that is clear now
unfortunately the citizens are in the
cleanup mode of course there's damages
inside they have to call their insurance
but that part is behind us three deaths
in the province have been attributed to
the storm so far Quebec energy Minister
Pierre Fitzgibbon says it's too many and
is urging people to take precautions
barbecues that they like to be outside
let's leave them outside we need to be
careful with the wires with you to be
careful with the branches so I think
security is at the uh is very very very
important the
major regions across Quebec while
Canada's three major telecon companies
say they will waive most data overage
fees for those affected by the outages
this month Elizabeth ogales Global News
Montreal
and that nasty storm also knocked out
power to parts of Ontario including the
nation's capital tonight more than ten
thousand people in Ottawa and the
surrounding region are still in the dark
more than fifteen thousand customers in
neighboring Gatineau Quebec and utatawei
region are facing the same challenges
an unprecedented legal decision in the
U.S could threaten abortion access for
millions of Americans yesterday a
federal judge in Texas suspended the
approval of a widely used abortion
medication but almost immediately after
that another judge in Washington state
made the exact opposite ruling as Sharia
Israel reports the dueling decisions are
setting the stage for a battle in the
U.S Supreme Court
okay and then this is the medicine for
tomorrow the abortion pill miffapristone
has been on the markets for two decades
and in that time has become the most
common way in the U.S to end in early
pregnancy millions of women have lost
access to abortion care especially here
in Texas so the access to medication
abortion is one of the last options that
we have but a federal judge in Texas
wants the drug off the shelves I think
this is absolutely appropriate uh there
has to be some kind of check on the FDA
and on a pro-abortion Administration
judge Matthew kesmerick appointed by
Donald Trump suspended FDA approval
in his decision the judge sided with
anti-abortion groups claiming federal
Regulators ignored health risks but
Decades of medical research around the
world contradict the judge's ruling
there's over 100 studies indicating the
safety of Memphis Stone uh it's much
safer than many other drugs such as
Viagra for example and it's just
um anti-abortion sentiment that's behind
this whole drive to stop the abortion
building has nothing to do with science
which solidly supports methopristone the
decision in Texas was challenged almost
immediately by a judge in Washington who
ruled the government can't restrict
access to abortion pills
for now miffapristone is still available
and the Biden Administration plans to
appeal it is contrary to what makes for
good Public Health policy to allow
courts and politicians to tell the FDA
what it should do but the competing
court cases in Texas and Washington will
likely head to the U.S Supreme Court
which overturned Roe vs Wade last year
we have too many right-wing judges in in
too many top positions in the Judiciary
in the United States who are really
putting through their own ideology and
not really looking at the rule of law a
legal standoff threatening to further
erode abortion rights in the U.S Taria
Israel Global News Ottawa
a trip to Florida has gone terribly
wrong for a New Brunswick man and his
wife he became injured while on vacation
and he ended up in hospital and now he's
trying to get transferred to a Canadian
facility but as Zach power explains
that's proved impossible
it was a normal trip for 82 year old
Patricia Bates and her 84 year old
husband Joseph guthro a bus took the two
on a tour from New Brunswick through the
U.S to Florida my husband decided to use
the washroom at the back of the bus and
on his way there the A car pulled out in
front of us and the driver had to slam
on the brakes real hard and my husband
fell down his fall compressed a disc
Joseph has been relearning the walk
since like a pain only left leg he's
been in a Florida Hospital for almost
two weeks now now the story is there are
no beds available
anywhere in New Brunswick in fact they
said it was bad all across the country
but there would be at least have been
there he'll need physiotherapy when he
returns to New Brunswick the province's
Dan Cassidy Center for rehabilitation in
Fredericton only has 20 beds according
to the couple all of which are occupied
do you have family that you've been
staying with I'm just staying here with
him hey he doesn't like to be here alone
there's I mean there's nobody else
there's only me
Bates has been sleeping in a chair next
to her husband they don't have any of
her family in the area they can go to
the Canadian government don't seem to
give a damn about her
citizens
ain't going to get help Global Affairs
Canada told global news that they're in
contact with local authorities to
provide Consular assistance but the
couple says that there's still no
timeline and when they'll be able to
return home to get care in New Brunswick
Zack power Global News Saint Stephen New
Brunswick
Canada's national justice department and
Military are getting hit with an 11
million dollar lawsuit from the
ex-husband of an Edmonton Soldier the
man claims the military failed to
adequately investigate his former wife
despite the concerns he repeatedly
raised but the safety of the former
couple's children the mother was
convicted of trying to murder the
children by burning down The Family Home
in 2015. in a statement of claim the
father argues it shouldn't have taken so
long for his ex-wife to be arrested
the Department of Defense is now
commenting on the matter as it is now
before the courts no one in the family
can be identified because of a
publication ban that's protecting the
children who are plaintiffs in this suit
it has long been a major point of
contention for the federal government
and the opposition despite many
arguments backing the importance in
fighting the climate crisis
conservatives have criticized the
federal carbon tax as being too costly
for Canadians now a new report from
Canada's parliamentary budget officer is
adding more fuel to the fire suggesting
certain people may benefit more from
rebates because of the tax but with a
very important catch Mackenzie gray
explains
please
treat each other with respect it's one
of the hottest issues in Parliament why
won't they ditch this tax plan and come
up with a real climate plan and the
temperature ratcheted it up yet again
there's a new report from the
Parliamentary budget officer into the
cost of the carbon tax Eve Giroux
finding that most Canadians would
receive more in rebates than they pay
because of the tax on a net basis most
households in provinces where the carbon
tax applies will be better off that's a
political win for the Liberals but when
the PBO took into account the full
economic impact to the carbon tax it was
a cloudier view the Watchdog found the
tax won't be Revenue neutral for most
families as the Liberals said it would
the PBO is saying the levy will drive
down wages and raise costs both
households are expected to be worse off
under a carbon tax regime than without a
carbon tax regime except for those at
the bottom end of the income scale a
political opportunity for the
conservatives the claims that Canadians
get more back and rebates for their
failed carbon tax has been proven false
by the public budgeting officer the
climate rebate will make 8 out of 10
families better off that is in PBO
report the former Minister who brought
in the policy believes the PBO didn't
account for the economic impacts of
climate change look I don't even
understand this report and I've spent a
ton of time on carbon pricing we're
paying the costs now and we need to take
action in a smart way that leaves
Canadian better off that actually
creates innovation in jobs that we
desperately need and of course that
tackles climate change but Canadians
might not be willing to spend the money
required to tackle the problem if you
ask Canadians they want to see more
action from government on climate change
if you ask them if they want to pay more
they obviously say no the carbon tax
rose again on April 1st to move it up to
65 dollars per ton of carbon dioxide and
it's set to continue to increase every
year by 15 until 2030. Mackenzie gray
Global News
Ottawa tensions are rising in Asia as
China kicks off another round of
military drills surrounding Taiwan the
independent Island which Beijing claims
as its own says China's warships and
fighter jets have crossed the boundary
which unofficially separates China and
Taiwan live fire drills will also be
involved the exercises which are set to
last three days are widely seen as China
retaliating after taiwan's president
headed to California to meet with the
U.S House speaker who reaffirmed
America's support for taiwan's autonomy
Canada's recession not as deep as one's
thought coming up what economists say
could help us Dodge a steep downturn in
the next few months plus music therapy
in Montreal the soundtrack surprising
patience and promoting healing
[Music]
while inflation has cooled in recent
months many people are still tightening
the purse strings which means that many
small businesses are still seeing their
bottom lines take a hit and in all
spawns speculation about a recession and
most Canadians are expecting one this
year according to a new survey from the
Bank of Canada economists are weighing
in and as Ann gaviola explains they
can't agree on if or when a recession is
on the way
what goes up must come down by
aggressively hiking interest rates over
the past year the Bank of Canada has
slowed the economy by making the cost of
borrowing more expensive which in turn
takes a bite out of demand which cools
inflation
the big question will the economy see a
rough Landing with economic turbulence
or a so-called soft Landing with a
smoother outcome well it depends on who
you ask maybe we get one negative course
or a positive quarter I'd probably
characterize that as a bumpy Landing you
know it's not quite soft not quite the
hard Landing but certainly not not a
great outcome many economy Watchers say
the strength of our labor market will
act as a buffer even if the U.S our
biggest trading partner falls into a
recession our base case forecast
continues to be a relatively mild
recession in Canada in 2023. we expect
to see the Canadian economy enter a mild
recession Capital economics says robust
immigration with more new Commerce
spending bolstering the economy May save
the day so spending per person may fall
but overall spending would stay the same
or even climb the only thing in my mind
that could Rescue Canada this year would
be sort of the immigration point maybe
immigration just remains exceptionally
strong predicting what's to come is
complicated inflation remains stubbornly
High trouble in the American banking
sector has many investors and lawmakers
on edge in this week's surprise
production cut by the OPEC plus cartel
of oil producing Nations is expected to
drive Global oil prices higher industry
experts say we could be in for one
hundred dollar a barrel oil later this
year which can weigh on everyday people
but be a boost to Canada's energy sector
what happens next is anybody's guess way
back in 2008 just on the eve of the
global financial crisis there were still
economists suggesting that the US would
avoid a recession and then obviously it
ended up being one of the deepest
recessions involved since the Great
Depression no one is suggesting we're on
the cusp of a shock of that magnitude
but many are bracing for economic storm
clouds ahead just the same Ann gaviola
Global News Toronto
[Music]
Trump's odds ahead after a
history-making week a former Insider
speaks to global news about his old
boss's re-election chances
Donald Trump made history this week for
all the wrong reasons he's now the first
U.S president former or current to be
charged with criminal offenses as he
fights the charges how could this affect
his fight to reclaim the White House in
2024. our Mercedes Stevenson spoke with
two top political pundits one of whom
used to be in Trump's Inner Circle
Mercedes
borrow there have been a range of
reactions from both Republican and
Democratic leaders in the U.S after the
charges were announced against former
U.S president Donald Trump to some they
were flimsy accusations far less
significant than what they were
expecting but others thought that the
indictments were damaging and will hurt
the former president's re-election
chances I put the question about what
this will all mean for Trump's political
future to his former press secretary
Sean Spicer Spicer says that in a slew
of legal troubles that Trump is facing
this case coming first may actually help
him it is going to look like the entire
system has been weaponized and is coming
after Trump and he's going to be able to
appoint at those additional cases and
say this is just another attempt to come
after me whether or not they are
stronger or weaker going forward because
this case went first and it is so weak
and so politicized political strategist
Rick Wilson says the Democrats have to
beat Trump not just legally but
politically because legal Jeopardy won't
be enough to to defeat the former
president there are plenty of ways to
beat Trump but Miracles aren't a
strategy hope is not a strategy and and
I I am a very Stern critic of this of
former president Trump one of the
sternest I would I think it could be
argued
um and I don't think the cases here as
of yet except for Jack Smith pose an
existential threat to the guy you've got
to beat him not just in the courtroom
and look he should be held accountable
either way Donald Trump Remains the
favorite choice of Republican voters
despite his ongoing legal troubles and
his role in the underwhelming midterm
election results any potential trial
related to these felony charges will
likely not take place until next year at
the earliest there is one thing for
certain in the immediate future and that
is that Donald Trump will continue to
dominate the headlines pharah
that's for sure thanks Mercedes and you
can catch Mercedes full interview with
former White House Press Secretary Sean
Spicer tomorrow morning on the west
block right here on global
[Music]
profound concerts for cancer patients
when they need it most
foreign
when you find out you have cancer but
research from McGill University has
shown there is something that can help
reduce stress and anxiety for patients
music that's why the Cedars Cancer
Center in Montreal has started concerts
Felicia Perillo with the special
soundtrack to healing and Recovery
it's not quite what people are used to
seeing at a Cancer Center
a Pianist accompanied by an opera singer
delivering a dose of classical music in
the middle of the day catching many off
guard the program that we started about
almost three years ago right before the
pandemic hit
the idea is to Enlighten the mood a
little bit in the cancer center where
it's often very quiet very somber
the program called Cedar's healing notes
came to life after harboyan a penis
herself accompanied a family member to
the center and thought it would be the
perfect place for a piano with the help
of these Cedars Cancer Foundation and
other players a baby grand piano was
installed and later the idea of one-hour
concerts was born
you know they're here in a cancer center
it's not always easy they have
treatments they have their disease on
their mind so to be able to give them an
hour where they can take their mind off
of their current stress and to be maybe
in another place enjoy the music is very
restful for them
the tunes are not only helpful for
patients also for family s and even
Healthcare professionals at the center
many say the concerts provide a peaceful
moment of pause or distraction I've just
come from seeing the oncologists we've
got to arrange different treatment
different medication
and uh in this was a wonderful finish to
that day because I did not know this was
going on the music varies from week to
week jumping from Jazz to popular or
classical music once a month
professional musicians take Center Stage
other times it's students from McGill's
Schulich School of Music who get a
chance to share their talent
we know that patients often spend a fair
amount of time in this cancer center and
it can be long so I think having a
moment of music is a gift
a powerful gift that truly keeps on
giving
[Music]
Felicia Perillo Global News Montreal
and that's global national for this
Saturday I'm far in osser on behalf of
our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is the
mountains of Kelowna British Columbia we
love senior Canada so please keep
emailing us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign